der plan für ein klimaneutrales europa
was die eu kommission an konkreten
gesetzen vorschlägt und was das für uns
alle bedeutet proteste plünderungen und
viele tote in südafrika eskaliert die
gewalt
es strömt es donnert es schüttet weite
teile deutschlands versinken im
dauerregen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber einen guten mittwoch
abend hinein und willkommen bei uns
kristin otto hat nachher den sport im
blick die königsetappe der tour guten
abend im kampf gegen den klimawandel hat
europa einen konkreten plan bekommen ab
2035 sollen zum beispiel keine neuen
benzin- und dieselautos mehr auf den
markt kommen
das ist teil eines gesetzespakets dass
die eu kommission heute vorschlägt um
ihr klimaschutzziel zu erreichen und so
sieht dieses ziel aus bis 2030 soll in
der eu der ausstoß von treibhausgasen um
55 prozent gegenüber dem stand von 1990
sinken
öl und gas müssten teurer werden einen
sozialfond würde im gegenzug die folgen
für mieter und pendler abfedern
außerdem sind klimazölle geplant für
waren die außerhalb der eu nach weniger
streng regeln produziert wurden britta
spiekermann jetzt mit den details ursula
von der leyen hat den green deal die
europäische energiewende einmal mit der
mondlandung verglichen
das ist sehr hoch gegriffen und auch
heute stapelt sie nicht tief
das übergeordnete ziel war und ist aus
europa den ersten klimaneutralen
kontinent in der welt zu machen und eine
neue wachstumsstrategie aufzubauen und
dieses ziel zu erreichen
die eu will bis 2050 klimaneutral sein
besonders hohes co2 einsparpotenzial
beim straßenverkehr der letzte neuwagen
mit verbrennungsmotor soll 2035 verkauft
werden die zukunft auf den straßen ist
also vor allem elektrisch mit einem
großen aber ein konkretes aus für den
verbrenner bedeutet das gleichzeitig die
rahmenbedingungen auch stimmen müssen
und für das elektrofahrzeug bedeutet
dass insbesondere eine verlässliche
funktionierende dichte ladeinfrastruktur
ein weiteres klimaschutzziel wer co2
ausstößt soll zahlen ein eigener
emissionshandel für verkehr und gebäude
wird fahren und wohnen teurer machen
auch die industrie soll stärker zur
kasse gebeten werden für ihren co2
ausstoß die sorge wettbewerbs
nachteile diese belastungen haben die
industrielle wettbewerbsfähigkeit schon
in der vergangenheit arg gefährdet und
sie werden das auch in der zukunft noch
mehr tun um die europäische industrie zu
schützen ist eine co2 grenze abgabe
geplant klimaschädlich hergestellte
produkte die aus drittstaaten eingeführt
werden könnten mit einem zoll belegt
werden viele pläne die umgesetzt werden
sollen ein mammutprogramm das paket geht
in die richtige richtung es ist
überfällig und es bedarf aber auch noch
stärkerer ambitionen noch schnellerer
maßnahmen und wichtig ist es dass diese
maßnahmen so schnell wie möglich
umgesetzt werden
doch schnelligkeit ist nicht gerade eine
paradedisziplin der europäischen union
jetzt wird verhandelt mit den
mitgliedstaaten ziele und maßnahmen
könnten durchaus noch verbessern und da
haben wir noch fragen an volker anders
aus unserer umwelt redaktion volker
gundrum ist das jetzt der entscheidende
schritt den europa da tun will um die
klimakrise in griff zu bekommen
entscheidende schritt das wird sich erst
in ein paar jahren herausstellen ist ein
notwendiger schritt und er kommt
eigentlich 20 jahre zu spät denn solange
es zeit verstrichen ohne dass wirklich
eine greifen der eu klimapolitik eben
durchgeführt worden ist aber jetzt ist
es tatsächlich so weit ist muss man
gucken zwei jahre lang werden die nach
verhandlungen noch dauern bis das
programm endlich greift dann sind es nur
noch sechs und halb jahre bis 2030 und
dann gas geben und dann wirklich
radikalen klimaschutz betreiben das ist
wirklich extrem anspruchsvoll und es
rettet das weltklima natürlich auch
nicht dazu müssen wir die vielen anderen
ländern klimakonferenz die nächstes jahr
in glasgow im november alle dazu bringen
etwas ähnliches zu tun
und dann gucken noch mal ganz konkret
wie wirkt sich das alles auf uns auf
unseren alltag
na wenn man ganz positiv denken kann man
sagen wenn das alles gut läuft super die
junge generation hat saubere luft ist
der klimaschutz ist im griff
modernes leben alles in ordnung das ist
sozusagen die gute utopie ich würde
sagen es gibt es schwierige
übergangsphase zunächst mal werden
fossile energieträger ja teurer also
alle die mit gas mit öl heizen müssen
sich auf mehrkosten einstellen bei den
autos sowieso der sprit wird auch teurer
werden
dann ist es aufgabe der politik
sozusagen gegen zu steuern in
deutschland ist im gespräch den
strompreis zu senken um zum beispiel die
eeg-umlage abzuschaffen das wäre eine
gewisse entlastung ist aber auch nicht
ganz fair denn nur wer viel strom
verbraucht merkt dass dann der unterm
strich also da kann man sehen da ist
noch unglaublich viel ausgleich zu
schaffen soziale ausgleich muss her
aber für die industrie das sei ja im
beitrag auch völlig zu recht angemerkt
da müssen auch sachen erfunden werden
damit nicht von außen der grüne strahl
einfach nicht mehr weg gekauft werden
kann weil er zu teuer ist das sind große
aufgaben in den nächsten zonen zu vier
jahren und wie gesagt wir werden dann 20
30 bilanz ziehen wir zwar vielleicht
nicht mehr nicht wirklich gedanken
volker angriffs heute abend zu diesem
hintergrund erläuterungen bei uns live
im studio und jetzt zu dem thema das
nach ansicht von experten bereits ein
bote des klimawandels ist die ganze
unwetterserie in diesem dauerregen
sommer im westen deutschlands hängt das
tief und damit der regen weiter fest
dazu gleich mehr
schauen wir erstmal auf das was gestern
abend hier in lila in südbayern begann
eine gigantische gewitterfront zog nach
norden
sintflutartige regen mengen kamen
darunter besonders die menschen in
oberfranken in thüringen und im
erzgebirge traf es heftig petra neubauer
fasst zusammen
wohin dieser man auch schaut von überall
raus das wasser heran im landkreis hof
hat das unwetter kurz aber umso heftiger
gewitter sind durch tolga farbe autos
und abgesoffen also sieht fürchterlich
aus baumstämme sind mitgerissen worden
unglaublich die feuerwehr kommt einfach
nicht mehr nach ständig wird sie zu
neuen einsätzen gerufen die helfer an
der grenze der belastbarkeit
ist überhaupt momentan eigentlich
überhaupt ermöglicht haben ein überblick
zu haben wo jetzt was unterwegs ist
[Musik]
ein ähnliches bild im benachbarten
vogtlandkreis die wassermassen schießen
durch straßen in die häuser und
hinterlassen völlig aufgelöste bewohner
katastrophe und beschreibt im schnitt
concord nett beschreiben
hier stimmt alles weg im sächsischen
stadt machen sich die menschen große
sorgen um einen 53-jährigen er wollte
sein grundstück sichern und wird von den
fluten mitgerissen was in alle welt
geschockt wenn man das hört sie gar
nicht der schlimmste befürchten denn
bislang wurde der mann nicht gefunden
bis zu 80 liter regen pro quadratmeter
bringt das unwetter und es wirkt nach im
landkreis hof etwa blieben heute einige
schulen und auch kitas geschlossen und
das alles ist noch lange nicht vorbei im
westen gibt es weiterhin dauerregen die
schäden sind schon jetzt beträchtlich in
hagen westfalen brachten die fluten
autos ins rutschen viele keller sind
vollgelaufen und mit dem hochwasser
kommt auch geröll und schlamm in die
straßen
das stark regengebiet erwischt auch die
eifel bäche und kleinere flüsse steigen
bedrohlich schnell an
in aller eile werden überall schutzwälle
errichtet und wir gehen jetzt live zu
marion geiger in der eifel marie und wie
ist denn die situation jetzt aktuell ja
aktuell steigen die flusspegel immer
weiter an am zwar wirklich so dass man
geradezu zugucken kann also alleine in
der letzten halben stunde sind die pegel
der umliegenden flüsse hier um halben
meter gestiegen
wir sind im eifelkreis bitburg-prüm er
ist für zweieinhalb stunden auch der
katastrophenalarm ausgerufen worden
ich stehe hier in dem kleinen flusses
dass es normalerweise einfluss der 45
meter breit ist und er ist jetzt richtig
breit und reißend geworden auch die
zuflüsse hier die rollen richtig brodeln
und gurgelnd die hänge herab und die
feuerwehr fährt jetzt sozusagen im
minutentakt einsätze es kommen immer
mehr meldungen dass keller vollgelaufen
sind und dieses ganze wasser hier aus
der region also alle flüsse hier die
dann in die mosel fließen zuflüsse zur
mosel sind die werden natürlich ganz
viel wasser auch an die mosel bringen
und die mosel entlang die orte trier
kochen koblenz die breiten sich alle auf
hochwasser vor
da werden jetzt hochwasser schutzwände
aufgebaut und ähnliche maßnahmen
getroffen und da in koblenz wird der
höhepunkt des hochwassers
am freitagmorgen erwartet maria und
herzlichen dank und wir sehen und hören
es regnet immer weiter bei ihnen zum
thema extremwetter gibt es gleich um
halb acht ein zdf heute live mit unserer
meteorologin katja horneffer zu sehen
auf zdf heute in der app und unseren
social media kanälen in der zdf gibt es
auch weitere hintergründe zu diesem nun
ja sommerwetter in deutschland unser
nächstes thema hier in der sendung in
den niederlanden verbreitet sich das
corona virus gerade rasend schnell
die regierung hat schon wieder fast alle
öffnungen zurückgenommen
heute wird bekannt bei einem
musikfestival in utrecht anfang des
monats haben sich 1000 menschen
infiziert obwohl nur geimpfte und
getestete aufs gelände durften für
deutschland registrierte das
robert-koch-institut 1548 neue
infektionen innerhalb eines tages das
sind 563 mehr als vergangenen mittwoch
die sieben tage incident steigt auf 7,1
anderes thema jetzt unser geld die
deutschen zahlen am liebsten in bar
doch das wird sich ändern denn alles
wird digital auch die währung bitcoin
zum beispiel auch online bezahlsysteme
per handy mit karte oder über anbieter
wie paypal werden immer wichtiger
sie könnten den euro irgendwann
verdrängen
die muss die europäische zentralbank
etwas entgegensetzen will sie hüterin
unseres geldes bleiben
ihre antwort ein digitaler euro mehr von
stefan schlosser es ist ein angriff auf
den euro drückt o währungen wie bitcoin
die sich staatlicher kontrolle entziehen
und projekte von konzernen wie facebook
die an einer eigenen digitalen währung
arbeiten drängen auf den markt werden
viele menschen so eine währung nutzen
würde der euro an einfluss verlieren
darauf müssen die zentralbanken
reagieren wenn sie nicht die hoheit über
das finanzwesen verlieren wollen und
deshalb brauchen wir einen ein digitaler
euro wäre wie das bargeld direkt von der
europäischen zentralbank garantiert kein
ausfallrisiko kein wertverlust
beim elektronischen bezahlen
organisieren bisher private konzerne die
abwicklung die meisten sitzen im ausland
und sie sammeln daten beim digitalen
euro könnte jeder ein konto bei der ezb
haben die datenschutz-anforderungen
wären hier deutlich strikter und könnten
besser kontrolliert werden
faktisch sind wir sehr abhängig vor
allem von ausländischen infrastrukturen
wenn wir zum beispiel auf die großen big
player schauen apple google et cetera
daten werden außerhalb der euro-zone
gespeichert und hier wäre eine wirklich
europäische lösung für ein digitales
system besonders wichtig schnell sicher
kostengünstig und fit für eine
digitalisierte welt die vorteile eines
digitalen euros für seinen erfolg müssen
sich aber vor allem die verbraucher vom
nutzen überzeugen lassen
wenn ich zahlen möchte und mein
gegenüber hat diese bezahllösung nicht
und kann meine zahlung nicht annehmen
dann funktioniert die zahlung nicht also
es ist ganz wichtig dass wir eine breite
nutzung und akzeptanz des digitalen
euros abend mit rund fünf jahren für
entwicklung und test phase rechnet die
ezb erst danach soll abschließend
entschieden werden ob der digitale euro
wirklich kommt und jetzt nach südafrika
wo seit tagen heftige unruhen gibt
ausschreitungen plünderungen tödliche
übergriffe auslöser die inhaftierung von
ex präsident jacob zuma die
gewalttätigen proteste begannen in
dessen heimat provinz im osten des
landes sie breiteten sich in die
metropole johannesburg und in weitere
provinzen aus bislang gab es mindestens
72 tote es brennt in südafrika
wortwörtlich sandra teils ein kleinkind
wird aus einem brennenden gebäude
geworfen
und bereitet auch heute wurden
einkaufszentren und geschäfte geplündert
zerstört in brand gesteckt so wie hier
in durban aufnahmen aus soweto gestern
plünderer greifen sich was sie zu fassen
bekommen für die geschädigten ist es
eine katastrophe
ich habe hier mindestens vier menschen
beschäftigt was wird jetzt aus ihnen das
ist nicht fair
wir wissen dass die arbeitslosigkeit
hoch ist
aber wenn sie so etwas tun wird die
arbeitslosigkeit noch größer mit
politischem protest hat das kaum noch zu
tun
armut und arbeitslosigkeit sind durch
die kurve pandemie gestiegen manch einer
sieht im chaos eine chance ganze
gewerbegebiete sind zerstört vor allem
in kwazulu natal gibt es lieferengpässe
der andrang vor geöffneten
lebensmittelgeschäften ist mancherorts
gros der präsident warnt wir werden
schon bald ein sehr hohes risiko einer
knappheit von nahrungsmitteln und
medikamenten haben
mittlerweile unterstützt das militär die
polizei
doch ein ende der gewalt ist derzeit
nicht in sicht
die menschenrechtslage in china ist
besorgniserregend sagen nicht nur
hilfsorganisationen menschenrechtler
werfen der regierung in peking vor
systematisch volksgruppen zu
unterdrücken
die usa und die eu haben sanktionen
gegen china verhängt es geht vor allem
um die muslimische minderheit der
uiguren bis zu eine million menschen
mussten nach schätzungen von
menschenrechtsorganisationen bereits in
umerziehungslager in der region shin
young soll es 380 solcher lager geben
unser china korrespondent ulf röller ist
dort gewesen und zwar in der stadt
kashgar
die polizei in kaschgar steht an jeder
ecke zu beginn der reise läuft alles wie
chinas propaganda sich das wünscht
niemand hat etwas von systematischen
unterdrückung der uiguren gehört die
vorwürfe stimmen nicht sagen sie den
ausländern dass es uns allen gut geht
dann treffen wir drei algerische mädchen
fast beiläufig erzählen sie uns von
umerziehungslager
ohne das wort in den mund zu nehmen um
sie zu schützen machen wie ihre
gesichter unkenntlich
manche leute sind im punch i was ist das
punch es ist ein ort zum lernen viele
menschen sind dort deswegen sagen manche
dass sie nicht frei sind
kennt ihr einige persönlich ja mein
vater ist dort und ihr vater ist auch
dort meiner seit zwei jahren ihr vater
schon seit vier jahren
wir wollen zu einem möglichen
umerziehungslager unser fahrer bekommt
plötzlich einen anruf wird nervös
wahrscheinlich hat die polizei sich bei
seinem chef gemeldet er soll die
ausländer loswerden
schnell schnell schnell ihr müsst jetzt
raus es sind noch drei kilometer das
gelände ist gesichert wie ein gefängnis
im hinteren teil soll sich das
eigentliche lager befinden
offiziell ist das hier eine parteischule
aber es gibt auch eine menge hinweise
dass dies ein umerziehungslager ist wir
haben drinnen die beiden wachtürme
gesehen wir sehen diese riesige mauer
hier die das gelände einrahmt und den
stacheldrahtzaun drumherum
also das ist sehr stark gesichert das
friedliche bild von kaschgar täuscht es
ist die stadt in der viele kinder ohne
eltern aufwachsen mehr von ulf röller
nachher im auslandsjournal jetzt
christin und die tour und die show des
gipfelstürmer die königsetappe der tour
eine unglaubliche herausforderung mit
drei bergen 3000 höhenmetern und der
mann in gelb kontrolliert souverän das
geschehen als tagessieger baut der
slowene hd boccaccio seine
spitzenposition aus angriff ist die
beste verteidigung
8 km vor dem ziel dezimierter depot
garger die konkurrenz nur zwei können
folgen der däne ringe und der
ecuadorianer carabas der col de portet
ihn wolken 16 kilometer schlussanstieg
mit durchschnittlich 9 prozent
roger kontert auch den letzten antritt
von carabas zeigt seine spurtqualitäten
auch auf luftigen 2200 metern höhe seine
nunmehr schärfsten verfolger hält er mit
über fünf minuten auf abstand
ein fantastischer tag
die etappe zu gewinnen einfach
unbeschreiblich zu boden geht der
slowene erst nach der ziellinie ab
dritten spieltag der neuen fußball
saison können die 36 vereine der ersten
und zweiten bundesliga auch mit
gästefans plan so ein beschluss der dfl
mitgliederversammlung demnach sollen
vorerst fünf prozent der tickets pro
spiel den gästen ermöglicht werden
als letzte mannschaft schafften die
basketball den sprung ins deutsche
olympiateam anfang juli ziemlich
überraschend als turniersieger in split
und genau diese zwölf spieler sind auch
ohne nba profi dennis schröder für tokio
hochmotiviert der star ist das team
auf diese formel hat sich bundestrainer
henrik rödl mit seinem zwölf spielern
beim abschlusstraining in trier
verständigt
ich glaube der mannschaft sehr sehr viel
zu wir werden kämpfen so wie wir das
gemacht haben jetzt in den letzten
spielen und dann wird man sehen was
dabei rauskommt
ohne nba star dennis schröder hatte sich
das team vor zehn tagen im letzten
moment für tokio qualifiziert
schröder der wegen zu hoher
versicherungskosten nur anfeuern konnte
wird wohl auch in tokio nicht dabei sein
wir gehen davon aus dass das nicht lange
der star ist das team mit großer
vorfreude auf tokio sonntag geht's los
ist abflug und warum man gehörigen
respekt vor der kraft eines gewitters
haben sollte das zeigen wir ihnen jetzt
noch das ist der berliner fernsehturm
vergangene nacht und das ganze noch ein
zweites mal der blitzableiter unter
hochspannung
der fernsehturm wird zwar häufig
getroffen aber so spektakulär nur selten
[Applaus]
die lottozahlen lauten heute 112 15 26
33 49 superzahl 6 weitere gewinnzahlen
im netz und im zdf text und noch die
aktuelle wetter warnung bis morgen früh
kann es im westen extrem ergiebigen
dauerregen geben wie gerade schon
gesehen etwa vom saarland bis rauf nach
dortmund auch wie viel regen wir uns
doch noch gefasst machen müssen und wann
sich alles beruhigen wird dazu gleich
mehr von katja honnefer ich empfehle ich
den kollegen claus kleber der hat das
heute journal um 21.45 und morgen gibt
es uns wieder
ich danke für ihr interesse und von uns
allen hier in allen einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
guten abend dass wir uns so lange mit
dem tief bernd beschäftigen müssen liegt
einfach daran dass es sich immer wieder
regeneriert es schnauft die warme und
feuchte luft aus richtung mittelmeer ein
und gleichzeitig auch die kühle und
trockene vom atlantik dabei holt ist die
wärme so richtig nach westen das sehen
wir gleich bei den temperatur karten bis
heute morgen 6 uhr sind innerhalb von 24
stunden hier in hirschberg hof und
querfurt mehr als 80 liter regen pro
quadratmeter gefallen heute über tag
waren es in köln ebenfalls bereits 80
liter und bis samstag sehen sie das hier
im westen und im süden noch mal 30 bis
120 liter regen pro quadratmeter
zusammenkommen
heute nacht also fällt kräftiger regen
im westen aber auch im süden sonst
lockern die wolken auch mal auf und dann
bildet sich nebel oder dunst und jetzt
sehen sie die interessanten temperaturen
die mild sind von rügen bis zum
niederrhein deutlich kühler ist es am
alpenrand mit neun grad am morgen liegen
die höchsttemperaturen wieder in dieser
kurve zwischen dem rhein main gebiet und
der lausitz bei 24 bis 29 grad im süden
ist es bei 17 bis 22 grad kühler
und auch morgen schüttet es ergiebig im
westen im nordosten ist es freundlicher
und erst zum wochenende beruhigt sich
die wetterlage guten abend